بعد فوزه بالانتخابات اردوغان يتعهد
بالوفاء بجميع وعوده
[موسيقى]
كاف تتعرض لاكبر هجوم جوي روسي منذ بدء
الحرب
مقتل فلسطيني في اشتباك مع قوات اسرائيليه
بالضفه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
بعد فوزه في جوله الاعاده من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في تركيا تعهد الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان امام انصاره بالوفاء بجميع ما
وعد به خلال حملته الانتخابيه اردوغان
الذي حصل على نحو
27.4 مليون صوت خاطب انصاره من شرفه قصره
قائلا ان الشعب كلفه برئاسه الجمهوريه
لخمس سنوات اخرى مضيفا انه سيسخر الجهود
للانتاج وتوفير الخدمات للشعب ومواجهه
اثار الزلزال والتصدي للتضخم وفيما يخص
اللاجئين السوريين اكد اردوغان انه يعمل
على اعاده نحو مليون لاجئ عبر توفير مساكن
لهم في المناطق الواقعه تحت سيطره الفصائل
المواليه لبلاده
[موسيقى]
اعلى وقع هجوم جوي روسي هو الاعنف منذ بدء
الحرب قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
العاصمه تتعرض لهجوم جديد استخدمت فيه
الصواريخ البالستيه رئاسه بلديه كيافا حتى
السكان على البقاء في الملاجئ كما اعلنت
الاداره العسكريه في كياف تفعيل انظمه
الدفاع الجويه في حين قال شهود عيان ان
دويا سمع في وسط العاصمه بعد انطلاق انذار
جديد من الغارات الجويه من جهته اكد
الكرملين ان العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
مستمره حتى تحقيق اهدافها
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه عن مقتل شاب
واصابه سبعه اخرين برصاص القوات
الاسرائيليه خلال الاشتباكات التي اندلعت
عقب اقتحامها لعده احياء في مدينه جنين من
جهته قال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان قوات الجيش والشبك وحرس الحدود اعتقلت
خلال الليل سته فلسطينيين من انحاء الضفه
الغربيه وصادرت اسلحه ومعدات قتاليه مؤكده
وقوع اضرار بعدد من المركبات العسكريه بعد
استهدافها بعبوات
الى اليابان الان التي اعلنت انها تلقت
اختارا من كوريا الشماليه تبلغها فيها
بعزمها اطلاق قمر اصطناعي خلال الاسابيع
المقبله فيما تعتقد طوكيو
تستعد لاطلاق صاروخ باليستي بعيد المدى
مكتب رئيس الوزراء الياباني قال في تغريد
عبر تويتر انه سيتعاون مع الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه ودول اخرى ذات
صله ويدعو الى ضبط النفس مضيفا انه سيجمع
المعلومات ويحللها اثناء استعداد اليابان
للخطوه الكوريه الشماليه
ونختم من نيوزيلندا حيث تمكنت الكاتبه
لليهود البالغه من العمر 80 عاما من
العوده الى عملها بالكتابه بعد توقف دام
اثني عشر عاما جراء اصابتها بالعمى وبعد
سنوات من فقدانها البصر بدات هد بالعلاج
عبر ارتداء خوذه تحتوي على بوصلات
كهربائيه لتحفيز الدماغ ثم تبين ان العلاج
لم يكن يتجاوز تحفيز ثروه الراس فقط لكن
وبشكل مفاجئ استعادت الكاتب بصرها بعد
اربعه اسابيع من العلاج الوهمي الامر الذي
اثار حيره الاطباء
[موسيقى]